before he was the director of Man of
Steel and Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice Zack Snyder weaved worlds within
worlds in sucker punch it's twisted
final act was left open to
interpretation and deemed
incomprehensible by many but we're here
to help with the ending of sucker punch
explained whose story is this one of the
key points of contention and
understanding sucker punch is
determining whose point of view the
story is actually being told from the
first and most straightforward idea is
that this is a story about baby doll
who's locked in an asylum and teams up
with four friends to escape in the
process she imagines herself as a
burlesque dancer and her dances within
the fantasy as elaborate battle
sequences baby doll doesn't escape in
the end but her fantasy helps tell the
story of how she got her friend Sweet
Pea out in her place the second
interpretation posits that all of this
happened as well except the fantasy is
in sweet peas head as she imagines her
friends who saved her as great warriors
in an epic story the third and most
complex is that almost nothing in the
film really happened and that it's all a
fantasy unfolding in sweet peas head as
she's about to be lobotomised when
watching the film it's an interesting
exercise to keep all three possibilities
in your head all the world's a stage
though many of the fantasy visuals and
sucker punch are there simply because
they look cool a few of the details hold
a deeper meaning including the very
first thing the film shows us Snyder
opens by showing us a child's bedroom
set on a stage then dissolves that set
into baby dolls bedroom during the death
of her mother when baby doll arrives at
the asylum we see another stage in the
room where dr. Gorski encourages her
patients to act out their trauma so this
is what we call Athena
it's they're sitting on the stage on a
bed with a striking resemblance to that
first shot of baby doll that we see
Sweet Pea for the first time it's also
there that dr. Gorski tells Sweet Pea
she's in control the recurring motif of
this stage plays heavily into the film's
running theme of performances salvation
particularly when baby doll dances to
get what she needs to escape but what if
it also signals to us that this is all
part of Sweet Pea controlling her little
world including the opening sequence in
baby dolls bedroom what if bats Sweet
Pea reliving her own trauma while the
club fantasy is Sweet Pea working
through it teenage lobotomy the real
world of sucker punch seems to show us
only one lobotomy baby dolls with the
prelude in the opening minutes in the
aftermath coming at the end there is
however a second lobotomy sequence at
the very beginning of the club fantasy
which Sweet Pea interrupts to argue
against performing a mock lobotomy on
stage and refers to herself as the star
of the show once again were offered two
versions of the same story we can choose
to believe that this is the story of
baby doll that she created a fantasy
world and that her lobotomy puts a stop
to it as she sacrifices herself to allow
speed to escape the asylum that's a
simple enough answer but it's not the
only one by showing a sweet peace
stopping her own lobotomy the film
offers up the idea that she is at least
in her own mind changing the way her
story is told instead of a mental
patient going under the knife she's a
warrior fighting to be free and the wig
is a hint that baby doll is in fact not
a separate person instead she's a
rebellious persona sweet pea has created
as a coping mechanism though she's
ultimately lobotomized anyway Sweet Pea
is free because the evil blue can't
reach the real her anymore a tale of two
sisters the parallels and baby doll and
sweet peas stories continue with the
revelation that rocket is sweet peas
sister and Sweet Pea is in the club and
by extension the asylum because she went
after rocket when she ran away from home
baby doll was committed to the asylum in
the first place by her violent
money-grubbing stepfather because she
accidentally killed her own little
sister while trying to save her which he
then used as the pretense to have her
locked up in other words both baby doll
sweetpea got where they are because they
went after their sisters sweet pea even
loses her own sister when rocket
sacrifices herself to save sweet peas
life the parallels are all they're
bringing sweet pea and baby doll closer
together and perhaps indicating that
they're one and the same
this might even explain why dr. Gorski
never mentions Rockets death or the
deaths of amber and blondie their
imaginary the wise man
virtually every character and Sucker
Punch with the speaking role exists both
as a persona in the club fantasy and as
a person in the asylum with one very
notable exception the wise man he first
appears in baby dolls Japanese battle
sequence and exists solely in the fight
scenes until the ending in which he's
revealed to be driving the bus that
takes Sweet Pea West we're never given
any context for who the wise man really
is but he only appears in the real world
after Sweet Pea is free of the asylum
and the fantasies concocted there which
leads to two different interpretations
of his place in the story sweet peas
narration throughout the film suggests
that she's telling the story from the
future if that's the case the wise man
is just a kindly bus driver she met
during her journey to freedom the other
possibility is that he's an invention of
her mind a kind and nurturing man who
speaks in fatherly platitudes dreamed up
by a young woman who's never known
anything but cruelty from men a one-way
trip to paradise in the final scene of
the movie we get one last clue to the
mystery of whether all of this is
happening in sweet peas head or if she
really did escape the asylum as the bus
she's riding on drives away it passes a
billboard for the Paradise diner back
when baby doll arrives at the asylum
bloom mentions that's exactly where
she'll be after her lobotomy there won't
be any of that for this one good it
should be paradise
I can't know what I mean if you believe
this is all happening in sweet peas head
the reference to paradise could mean
that Sweet Pea herself is somewhere in
her own mind where she's finally free
after the baby doll persona she created
sacrificed herself through the lobotomy
or perhaps Sweet Pea is just remembering
her friend and heading off into the
sunset to live a full life of paradise
on her behalf
we've gone through the clues but it's up
to you to decide for yourself it's like
we talked about you control this world
[Music]